On April 16th, 2017, Turks will head to
the polls and vote in a referendum. If
they vote yes, it will mean a new system
of government for Turkey. Leadership will
be under the executive authority of the
president, and the role of prime minister
will disappear. The president will be
able to appoint senior judges and will
also be able to dismiss Parliament. Now while
President Recep Tayyip Erdogan in Turkey
says he's really doing nothing more than
having a system like in the United
States, in reality that's not true. It
would be as if the president ruled in
the United States, but you didn't have a
Supreme Court, and you didn't have a
Congress either, to have the balance of
powers. Now many political opponents are
very nervous because of President Erdogan's
dictatorial tendencies. He's
already fired a hundred thousand people
and put more than fifty thousand others
in jail, but he refuses to allow those
opposed to him to campaign. What many
people see now is the formalization of
an autocracy - a dictatorship - rather than
a real new beginning for Turkey.
What are your thoughts in the video? What are your
thoughts on the referendum? Let us know
in your comments, and also let us know
what other topics you want AEI scholars
to cover in 60 seconds.